hey guys it's just stated today we are
reviewing the brand-new vlogging camera
from Sony now this isn't just a vlogging
camera basically they're comparing this
to one of their higher and mirrorless
cameras which is the a9 so to pack a lot
of things that people love about the a9
into this tiny point shoot is beyond
incredible but for me I don't really
take a lot of photos I do a lot of video
and I'm always on the hunt for the
perfect vlogging camera and so far we
are so so close to having a perfect
camera but this now officially has mic
jack it's about time that's all I'll say
the rx100 line has been one of my
favorite vlogging cameras for a long
time this is gonna change everything the
only thing that I ever wanted was a very
small point-and-shoot camera with a mic
input and not only we getting the mic
input but we're getting a super powerful
camera it takes incredible photos the
autofocus is just beyond anything that
you guys will expect from something so
small it has continuous IATA focus which
is something that I really love and it
also has Annamalai focus which only
works in still photos hopefully soon
they'll have a firmware update so you'll
be able to do that in video as well but
let's take a look at this thing so it
has the flip up screen that you guys are
used to in most of the RX lines this
also shoots 21 megapixels it has a 24 to
200 millimeter zoom look that's
excessive it doesn't have a built-in ND
filter which I used a lot in the rx100
Mark 5 but I think overall if you are
outside shooting you will notice a
little bit of a difference if you had
the previous version and you use the ND
filter quite often but man did I mention
that has a mic jack it uses the same
batteries as the previous versions so if
you have a bunch of these from your
older cameras you can still use those
but what I wanted to show you guys today
are some of the rigs that I have come up
with what I love about this is I am so
sick of lugging around a huge camera
like I don't want to do it anymore it's
exhausting and when I'm traveling I just
want to shoot get cool shots and not
have to be burdened with a bunch of
stuff so this is really really exciting
let me get my little basket of goodies I
went into my tech closet did a little
shopping and I picked out some things
that I think I will like to use with
this you guys have seen this before my
sister Jenna uses this a lot because she
vlogs a little bit more than I do
now it not only acts like a little
tripod but it also has some controls
here so you can take photos you can zoom
in and out you could also start and stop
recordings this is a very tiny little
microphone and this thing cost twenty
five dollars on Amazon one of the things
that I noticed with this camera is I had
been doing a bunch of mic tests and I
couldn't understand why some of the mics
would work and some of them wouldn't
it's a 3.5 millimeter jack why is this
not working there's various types of
these 3.5 milimeter jacks so this one is
a TRS and you can tell because it only
has one ring and this one is just a
little road log microphone so this is a
trrs
so it has two rings so if you do want to
use this you will need a little adapter
which I actually got one with this rode
mic so it will convert your trrs to a
TRS and you'll be able to use it so I
went on Amazon it was trying to find
these smallest TRS microphone that I
could find that would work with this so
this is how I like to use it and I just
plug it in just like so I did a quick
little video test with this in a
previous video but what I love about
this is it is so small and it sounds
really good so if I'm filming I can flip
it around and you can hear the audio
from here or I'm filming somebody else I
can just flip it right to the front so
there we go another weird little setup
that I was doing which is so dumb I was
just running this wire directly into the
camera and I was just clipping this to
my shirt and this makes it super simple
to just get really quick shots with a
really great audio I went to Maine
recently for a fun little vacation I've
never been to Maine a sidenote it's
beautiful so everybody that lives there
props on your homeland
it was super windy and I was about to
hop on the sailboat so I thought this
would be a perfect test of using this
little setup and all they get on the
sailboat I'm in Camden Maine right now
this is actually my first time in Maine
and it's so beautiful this is the boat
I'm about to get on this is the old lad
literature I keep calling the Olaf but I
think that might be
a snowman this is something that I'm
extremely excited about all of my other
youtuber friends everyone has basically
been using these these are the road
wireless girl microphones
I know Farooq is a huge fan of these and
he basically was like you gotta get it
and this is exciting because it's gonna
be a perfect setup for this little guy
it's another microphone option this is
the microphone that I always use when
I'm vlogging because it does work with a
hot shoe so in any of the Sony cameras
you can just plug this right in you
don't need any wires or anything that is
one thing that I really wish that this
would have but instead they have this
view finder so the view finder is really
great when you're out taking photos or
videos in really sunny situations I
think you'd be into that Tyler you like
the viewfinder don't you it's a long
scene using the viewfinder
okay well still got a new tripod option
also got this little bracket mount that
I use quite often and this one which I
just found is going to be honestly I
think the perfect thing for this setup
so this is super small and what's great
about these little rode mics is this
little clip
oh god this is actually the microphone
so you can look super silly and just
clip this to your shirt and like that's
a LOF so this little clip just clips
right here until like a cold shoe I mean
this is I mean this is seriously
game-changing I I'm shook so this looks
a little silly but honestly find me a
smaller setup I'll wait this is
everything I've ever wanted
look at this little big I may need to do
a little bit of cable management so far
this is my favorite rig but now I want
to do an audio test of what each one of
these options sound like this is the
audio of the on board Sony rx100 7 this
is what it sounds like with no
microphones attached absolutely nothing
this is it and who tell if I get a
little bit closer the audio
obviously is a little bit better because
it tolls you to the microphones so this
is probably about where I would be when
I'm vlogging now let's plug in the road
wireless go so this is the setup using
the road wireless go microphone I'm
using the law of connected to the little
wireless go I also want to try this out
without the wireless law I'm gonna
unplug this love from the little
wireless go and I don't know plug this
law directly into the camera so this
will give us an option of what it sounds
like if I decide to not use this and
just look silly with a cable hanging off
of my camera so that looks like it's
working and the love is attached to me I
look silly this is about as far I think
as I can get without pulling the camera
over it's definitely not a good look but
hopefully it sounds okay
now let's move on to my favorite little
tiny $24 nugget so this is a test of
this little tiny microphone and make
sure whatever you guys are plugging
things into this mic input that it's
pressed in all the way because I just
made a huge mistake and it wasn't pushed
it all the way and this was the audio
that I got from that shot and I also
love that I can flip it around so Tyler
say something so always make sure that
it's actually plugged in because I've
lost so much footage in the past because
of something so simple like that this is
what it sounds like with that other
little hotshoe Sony microphone how does
it sound
are you guys enjoying this so I'm a
little bit further away and obviously
I'd be vlogging probably about somewhere
right here okay audio test over another
thing that I love is you can do interval
shooting so you can also shoot raw and
JPEG so you can get some really high
quality time lapses I shot this it was
really dark so I'm surprised this came
out as well as it did this was the moon
rising above a lighthouse I'm so excited
that they have interval shooting in this
camera they first released it with a a
6400 and then they later released a
firmware update for some of their
mirrorless cameras so this it makes it
super simple and I also love that you
can shoot in RAW as well so you can get
some really high quality shots here's a
few photos that I took
most of these are just all in Auto I did
do a little color correcting in
Lightroom so they aren't directly from
the camera I also mentioned about
picture profiles which is really fun
especially if you do like to color grade
your footage and have more flexibility
so we're shooting an S log too so here's
what that shot looks like with a little
bit of color grading it's fantastic I'm
not very good at grading so don't judge
me for my skills there's also some new
steady shot options so there's active
standard and just off so if you do have
a non active it does crop the image a
little bit I would recommend probably
keeping it on standard unless you're
super unsteady can keep it on active
really I think just do what you want
these are just merely suggestions
whatever you think works do that I'm
gonna show you probably my ideal setup
which I will use most of the time so I
probably would most likely use this
tripod and use this little guy I really
really like this a lot after vlogging
for so many years it gets extremely
tiring and the shots that you can get
with this camera they're comparable to a
lot of these mirrorless cameras because
this is not an inexpensive camera this
is about $1,200 so you aren't paying for
something that is extremely powerful
another thing you guys know that I love
slo-mo shots
this also has high frame rate built into
it so there's a little high frame rate
option so you just flip that over to
there you hit the movie button a little
preview oh that's weird I don't like
that oh that's disgusting my fingers
look like they're gonna fall off my hand
I hate everything that I just filmed so
the high frame rate settings you can
shoot 240 480 and 960 frames a second
another thing that's really cool about
this camera is you can shoot 20 frames a
second continuous shooting with no
blackout and it'll just look like you're
filming a video but you're actually
taking photos
why absolutely love this camera I've
been having so much fun with ever right
now we're gonna go out and shoot a vlog
those days a fake of log but it's gonna
be a real vlog but it's like a forced
vlog for the sake of this camera so you
get the point
I've got to go vlog with us now so let's
go outside where should it go I want
coffee coffee please okay we're driving
we're going to get coffee if this is a
vlog this is a forced vlog we're forcing
an activity right now which is what most
vlogging is if anyone tells you
otherwise never complete liar horse vlog
coffee I'm forcing you guys to get
coffee for speaking general is
previewing the audio and she said it
sounded a little bit low so on the
actual camera itself you can adjust the
level so previously I had it at 15 and I
just changed it to 18 so jump test and
see how that sounds because I think this
will be better so it's my fault
if it's not better well I'm gonna get oh
my gosh me too no CVD because I already
had some CVD this morning and I think
it's I think it's swelling my tongue I
think I'm having a reaction can you do
that soon
no way look how fast that is okay I've
had one of these cameras for so long
could you do that at all of them yeah
I did not experiment in the settings
enough we're almost there
fast soon are you recording
ok this is super riveting content I am
putting money in the meter and we have
20 minutes so we're gonna need to make
haste make haste do do with haste be
hastily
do we all want how are you give us a
Jenna Jana's coffee thank you
here you go Jen they even have like
fresh homemade vanilla sugar it's
incredible thank you wouldn't mind - I
did yeah it's really good I think this
blog is going really well what have you
done so far
well we drove here oh we drank coffee
what will we do next this is that this
is all you I do like the two hundred
millimeter zoom I know right for nature
I am super into nature look with Tyler's
doing right now he's using the
viewfinder I knew you'd be so into that
do you like it yeah it's kind of cool
because a lot of cameras I can see like
yeah and the viewfinder at the same
so
throw something happening now
one of the other cool things this camera
has is it can detect the orientation
that the camera is being held so right
now jenna is holding this in a vertical
format so this will automatically flip
so this makes it super easy to import
photos and videos from that your camera
is directly to your phone and you post
an Instagram stories or I don't know I'm
super into vertical video I think it's
really cool and the by FedEx he almost
hit us I've been making it my goal to
make this my main camera that I travel
with so I went and got one of the rx100
small rigs this rig is so awesome it's
pretty low profile so it's not that huge
but you can see it has like a really
cool little grip on here and everything
fits so perfect it still gives you
access to all of the ports
it also allows you to have access to the
battery and SD card it's such a perfect
snug fit even the viewfinder fits and
guess what else the flash still works
you still have access to do the zoom
everything is just so perfect on this
like I can't believe it the main reason
that I got this is because I want to be
able to mount things on it I don't know
the proper mount yet but I have it
ordered and hasn't come in yet so right
now I've just been clipping of the rode
mic right on this just like so you can
clip it right on the rail and then plug
it in I mean
like who's not gonna want to vlog with
this setup like I might honestly start
vlogging again well thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed this video don't forget to
subscribe if you enjoyed this video and
make sure you like it and hit the bell
and do all the things that us youtubers
tell you to do here on YouTube this is
just Steam signing off hello and goodbye
why did I say that I've never said that
in my life
[Music]